[Musik]
anlegen für den finalen schuss
großwildjäger begeistert auf der jagd
sind leute die tiere abschießen für
profite die konsumieren afrikanische
wildtiere die schüsse in eine
elefantenherde ein blutiges vergnügen so
genannte trophäen jagten sind ein riesen
geschäft in der nicht auch tausende
deutsche machen jedes jahr in
afrikanischen ländern jagd auf elefanten
us on und co und bringen ihre
geschossenen trophäen mit nach hause
ganz legal und vom staat erlaubt
wir stoßen im netz auf diese
verstörenden videos hobbyjäger filmen
sich wie sie bedrohte wildtiere
erschießen und danach mit ihren trophäen
prahlen
unsere recherche beginnt 2009/10 hier
dortmund jedes jahr präsentieren sich
anbieter solcher trophäen jagten auf der
jagd & hund messe
[Musik]
sehr beliebt zurzeit cd big five das
heißt würfel leopard elefant und 34 35
wir wollen wissen was den reiz dieser
jagten ausmacht wir gehen ja nicht und
schießen tiere zum spaß am töten
darum geht es ja nicht es geht nicht um
spaß
es ist es gehört einfach dazu
es ist ein erlebnis das ist ein erlebnis
das ist alles geschäft an dieser media
greifen
bei dem geschäft kassierte wien
industriebetrieb sagen cool ist das
alles schaffen
aber nicht alle aussteller wollen mit
uns reden
deutschland ist drittgrößter
trophäenjagd nation
der import abgeschlossener tiere ist
legal selbst wenn sie unter artenschutz
stehen allein 2009 10 wurden 748
trophäen aus der ganzen welt nach
deutschland eingeführt darunter 19
getötete elefanten
dieser mann hat noch bis vor einigen
jahren dafür ein vor genehmigung erteilt
dietrich jelden ehemalige
abteilungsleiter im bundesamt für
naturschutz
jetzt hält er vorträge für den
internationalen jagdverband immer mit
der auslandsmarkt sind wichtige
ökonomische ökonomische
faktoren verbunden viele länder wo die
eine eine gut regulierte und und
nachhaltige und legale jagd anbieten
profitieren ökonomische natürlich von
von von solchen jagd touristen in
enormem maße ja tourismus ist ein
wichtiges instrument im international
atemschutz das wollen wir überprüfen die
reise nach namibia
dorthin wo die deutschen am liebsten
hinfliegen um trophäen zu schießen
etwa 2500 deutsche jäger pro jahr
[Musik]
wir besuchen juwi lamprecht im winter
der namibischen hauptstadt
er biete trophäen jagten an das
besondere an seinen reisen es sind
jagten in sogenannten conservancy den
schutzgebieten also dort wo die tiere
noch wild leben
es ist scarlett töten also wir wollen
daran gehen und es mal spannend sein es
muss schwer sein
wir wollen laufen wir wollen kirchen
winter diese tiere hinterhergehen
2009/10 mussten jäger bei juwi lamprecht
für einen giraffen abschuss 2.000 us
dollar zahlen wie ein nashorn abhängig
von der länge des horns bis zu 78 1000
dollar und für einen elefanten sogar
85.000 dollar es ist ein
millionenschweres geschäft was vor allem
hobby jäger aus nordamerika und europa
anlockt yoffie lamprecht behauptet auch
die bevölkerung verdiene gut an der
trophäenjagd es sei eine wichtige
einnahmequelle für die menschen die dort
in armut leben
diese leute kriegen dann meisten von dem
geld von die jagd gehen zu direkt sind
diese leute und ein kandidat diese geld
benutzen viel wasser löschen autos das
was die benutzten in diesen gebieten
wegen jahrelanger korruption ging aber
nur ein bruchteil des geldes an die
menschen in den jagdgebieten daher
beschloss die namibische regierung 2018
dass 50 prozent der einnahmen durch
trophäen jagten in soziale projekte vor
ort fließen müssen doch passiert das
wirklich wir fahren nach oma chatte vier
stunden von windhuk entfernt ein gebiet
seit jahren von dürre geplagten für
mensch und tier ist rar
im vergangenen jahr wurden im ort
wasserleitung verlegt finanziert durch
eine einmalige zahlung aus einer
trophäenjagd immer wieder ziehen
elefantenherden durch das dorf auf der
suche nach wasser das gemeindeoberhaupt
berner kurier zeigt uns die
wasserleitung die die elefanten
vergangene nacht aus dem boden gerissen
haben geld den schaden zu beheben und
die leitungen tiefer zu verlegen ist
nicht da sagte er
[Musik]
eigentlich müsste regelmäßig geld in die
schutzgebiete aus den trophäen jagten
fließen
das passiere aber nicht sagt benner
korea das argument tiere für den abend
schutz zu töten kann er nicht
nachvollziehen
[Musik]
ein weiteres argument einem irischen
regierung trophäenjagd finanziere den
kampf gegen wilderer nashörner sind
durch die wilderei besonders bedroht
nashorn pulver gilt vor allem in china
und vietnam als wundermittel preise von
50.000 euro pro kilo sind keine
seltenheit
wir wollen wissen ob sich der nashorn
bestand in namibia tatsächlich aufgrund
der trophäenjagd erholt hat wir machen
uns auf indigene region zu einer
privaten farm auf der nashörner
gezüchtet werden
wo genau die farm von jako müller ist
dürfen wir nicht sagen aus angst vor
wilderern in den 80ern sollen in namibia
nur noch 50 nashörner in freier wildbahn
gelebt haben um die ausrottung zu
stoppen wurden in den 90er jahren die
tiere auf mehrere private firmen
verteilt
[Musik]
mittlerweile lebt die größte population
afrikanischer spitzmaulnashörner in
namibia doch von den einnahmen der
trophäenjagd bekomme er keinen cent sagt
jako müller
er hat einen plan wie er den
schwarzhandel mit dem nashorn
unterbinden könnte er möchte das horn
der tiere legal verkaufen denn das
wächst nach nach einer betäubung der
tiere kann es abgesägt werden
[Musik]
das problem ist der verkauf der hörner
und des daraus gewonnenen pulvers ist
durch das washingtoner
artenschutzabkommen weltweit verboten
wir fahren zurück nach windhoek wollen
wissen wohin fließt eigentlich das geld
aus der trophäenjagd und wer
kontrolliert den geldfluss nachfrage
beim verantwortlichen ministerium
controlling geht die snort up to your
standards badu ja controlling and
disease week in brökers you're not that
into the wild things are things
networking
doch wenn weder der artenschutz noch die
stetige finanzielle unterstützung der
lokalen bevölkerung gewährleistet ist
warum sind solche jagdreisen und die
einfuhr der trophäen in deutschland
erlaubt schriftlich antwortet uns das
bundesumweltministerium die
bundesregierung setzt sich nicht für ein
pauschales importverbot ein um
schutzprojekte nicht zu gefährden
die auf einnahmen aus nachhaltiger
jagdtrophäen angewiesen sind
aktuelle zahlen belegen dass im
vergangenen jahr beispielsweise 19
elefanten sechs pumas 13 löwen zwei
breitmaulnashörner und 31 flusspferde
allein nach deutschland eingeführt
wurden
januar 2020
wir begleiten tierschützer auf die messe
jagd und hund die stimmung unter den
reiseanbietern ist gereizt
wir werden von den mitarbeitern der
messe dortmund nicht aus den augen
gelassen reihten sich schon seit zwei
stunden ein bisschen seltsam dass sie
uns hier die ganze zeit hinterher laufen
wie kommt's warum machen sie das
mehr
gegen die mit
heike henderson und peter rettig halten
die trophäenjagd grundsätzlich für
falsch
da sind leute die tiere abschießen für
profite die konsumieren afrikanische
wildtiere und die konsumieren am
liebsten die tiere das am seltensten
gibt und davon noch die größten also das
kann nicht nachhaltig sein also unsere
forderung es seit mehreren jahren schon
dass man die importe von diesen treffen
nach deutschland also bedrohter
tierarten nach deutschland beendet die
jagd wird dann immer noch geben aber es
werden sehr starkes zeichen
international wenn deutschland als
drittgrößte trophäenjagd nation nach den
usa und spanien
das verbieten würde und solange die
gelder aus trophäenjagd nicht wirklich
dauerhaft der lokalen bevölkerung zugute
kommen wird es einfach nur ein
todbringendes luxus hobby von
hauptsächlich weißen männern sei wie
findet ihr die jagd auf bedrohte
tierarten schreibt es uns in die
kommentare